president Trump announces he's been
taking hydroxychloroquine city's lacked
the courage of their lockdown
convictions and a columnist for The New
York Times decides believe all women was
a right-wing plot all along I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn calm / ban okay so
if you live on Twitter what you will
notice that there is a vast disconnect
between the crap that people care about
on Twitter and the stuff that happens in
real life like in real life we're all
worried about jobs we're all worried
about the stock market in our economy
and dying of Cova that there are actual
things to worry about in real life and
the good news is there's a bunch of good
news with regard to the real things
happening in real life and I want to
bring you that good news because frankly
I think it's much more important than
what is happening on Twitter but the
disconnect on Twitter is truly
astonishing there are a bunch of
important stories happening today and
then there's a bunch of random crap
happening that Twitter thinks is super
important and we'll get to all of those
things let's begin with the actual
important news so actual important news
it now appears that vaccines could be on
the way that doesn't mean that they will
be available for public consumption by
the end of the year but it does mean
that probably sometime early next year
we are looking at public consumption of
a vaccine for covet that drastically
reduces the death rate and this is
resulted in a skyrocketing stock market
according to the Associated Press
Asian shares rose Tuesday on optimism
about a potential vaccine for
coronavirus after hopes for a u.s.
economic recovery in the second half of
the year sent Wall Street into a rebound
the Japanese at benchmark Nikkei 225
added 1.9 percent in morning trading
Australia's S&P from 2% South Korea's
kospi was up almost 2%
the mood is assertively risk-on with
sentiment having been tipped over by
fresh hope sparked for a coven 19
vaccine says japan a market strategist
for IG massachusetts basement earnest
thought stocked rum 20% in new york
trading on monday the S&P 500 climb 3.2
percent that was its best day since
early April the gains erased all the
losses from last week when the index
posted its worst showing since late
March and its third weekly loss in the
last four bond yields rose broadly and
in other signs that investors were
becoming more optimistic bond yields
rise inversely proportional to demand
that means the demand for bonds drop
people are looking to invest in the
stock market as opposed to relying on
bonds investors were also encouraged by
remarks over the weekend from Fed
Reserve Charger on pal
he expressed expressed optimism that the
US economy could begin to recover in the
second half of the year once the
outbreak has been contained he said the
economy should be able to rebound
substantially and so you saw the S&P 500
gained 9
points and the benchmark index is still
down from about 13 percent from its
all-time high but that is not 30 or 40
percent the Dow Jones Industrial surged
almost 4% as well so that is some very
good news in other very good news it now
turns out that kovat patients who are
testing positive after recovery are not
actually infectious according to a new
study so there was some speculation that
you might still be positive for coven 19
and able to pass it to other people once
you had recovered from koban 19 that
apparently is not true according to
Bloomberg there's a report of a study it
says that people are only shutting dead
virus and so they're testing positive
for the dead virus but they are not
actually shutting into the public stream
which means that people are not actually
going to die after meeting someone who
has recovered from coven 19 which is
really really good news based on those
results according to a tool Gawande
who's a very well-respected healthcare
researcher he says the Korean CDC is
lifting requirements to have a negative
test for a turn to work or school after
a club of 19 infection under the new
protocols no additional tests are
required for cases that have been
discharged from isolation so that is
very good news as well in other news the
President of the United States is now
taking a hammer to the w-h-o which is a
good thing the President issued a letter
to the w-h-o basically saying you guys
need to stop being lackeys of the
Chinese government or we are simply not
going to participate in that which you
seek he wrote dear dr. Ted Rose on April
14 2020 i suspended US contributions to
the World Health Organization pending an
investigation by my administration of
the organization's failed response to
the coven 19 outbreak this review has
confirmed many of the serious concerns I
raised last month and identified others
that the w-h-o should have addressed
especially the World Health
Organization's alarming lack of
independence from the People's Republic
of China based on this review we now
know but following the w-h-o
consistently ignored credible reports of
the virus spreading in Wuhan in early
December 2019 or even earlier including
reports from The Lancet medical journal
the w-h-o failed to independently
investigate credible reports that
conflicted directly with the Chinese
government's official accounts even
those that came from sources within
Wuhan itself I no later than December
30th the world the World Health
Organization in Beijing knew there was a
major public health concern in Wuhan
between December 26th and December 30th
China's media highlighted evidence of a
new virus emerging from Wuhan by the
next day Taiwanese authorities had
communi
information to the WHL which they
ignored the internal health regulations
require countries to report the risk of
a health emergency within 24 hours
trying to not inform the w-h-o of all
hands cases of pneumonia of unknown
origin until December 31st even though
it likely had a knowledge of these cases
days or weeks earlier
according to dr. Chang Jung gen of the
Shanghai public health clinic center
he told Chinese authorities on January
5th he had sequenced the genome of the
virus there was no publication with this
information until six days later when
dr. Jang self posted it online
the next day the Chinese authorities
closed his lab for rectification as even
the WHI acknowledged dr. Jang's posting
was a great act of transparency but the
WHI has been conspicuously silent with
respects about the closure of Jiang's
lab and his assertion that he notified
Chinese authorities of his break to
break through six days earlier the WTO
has also made claims about coronavirus
that were either grossly inaccurate or
misleading On January 14th they
suggested no human human transmission on
January 24 On January 21st President Xi
Jinping of China reportedly pressured
the WHI not to declare the kelowna virus
outbreak in emergency and on January
22nd the w-h-o said that this was not a
public health emergency of international
concern On January 28th after meeting
with President Xi in Beijing dr. Ted
Rose praised the Chinese government for
its transparency even after the WHI
belatedly declared the outbreak a public
health emergency of international
concern January 30th they didn't press
China for the timely admittance of a
w-h-o team of international medical
experts and so that team didn't even
arrive until February 16th even then the
team was not allowed to visit Wu hen
until the final days of their visit also
the w-h-o strongly praised at China's
strict domestic travel restrictions but
were inexplicably against the closing of
the US border or the ban with respect to
people coming from China and the list
goes on and on and on of WTO failures
and so the president concludes until you
stop becoming basically a Lackey of the
Chinese government we're cutting off
your funding he says my administration
has already started discussions with you
on how to reform the organization but
action is needed quickly we don't have
time to waste that's why that is why it
is my duty as president of the United
States to inform you that if the w-h-o
does not commit to major substantive
improvements within the next 30 days I
will make my temporary freeze of us
funding to the w-h-o permanent and
reconsider our membership in the
organization okay so that's big news and
that is good news that's something good
the president Trump is doing we'll get
to more of the actual news and then
we'll get to all of the news that
apparently care about on Twitter in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that cell phone bills you know a
lot of your bills are going down right
now because the demand is just not there
and so supply has meant to man it is it
is way over demand and that way a lot of
prices are going not happening with your
cell phone bill right your cell phone
bill is still sky-high
well you've gotten used to it you don't
have to be used to those giant cell
phone bills and right now can you think
of a better time you need to save money
you need to switch to pure talk USA you
can cut costs and free up cash on a
monthly basis starting with your
wireless provider pure talk will cover
99% of Americans the president/ceo of
pure talk is us veteran who cares deeply
about serving Americans by making
wireless affordable I know my trust him
start your saving today dial pound at
250 say key word ben shapiro for
unlimited talk unlimited text in one gig
of data for 20 bucks a month plus you
will get 50% off your first month which
means 10 bucks your first month stop
paying too much too big wireless
providers switch instead to pure talk
today save 50% off your first month dial
palin 250 say ben shapiro again that's
pound 250 and then use key word ben
shapiro pure talk USA simply smarter
wireless people are paying an enormous
fortune for unlimited data that you're
not actually going to use instead just
go use pure talk USA right now and you
can get unlimited talk unlimited text
one gig of data for 20 bucks a month
plus you will get 50% off that first
month again all you have to do is dial
pound it to 50 and then when the
recording begins say my name ben shapiro
again that is pound 250 key word ben
shapiro for pure talk USA and save
yourself a bundle when you don't have to
spend a lot of money on your wireless
that's pure talk USA dial pound 250 and
then say my name ben shapiro
in order to get started okay so in other
news that is good there are a variety of
states that are that that are now
opening up for sports who are thinking
about opening up for sports that is a
that is a very good thing according to
the washington post the prospects for
the nation's professional sports leagues
for zoom operations were boost in Monday
when the governors of New York
California and Texas announced their
support for pro sports returning in
their states new york state is ready and
willing to partner with major sports
teams that are interested in playing
games safely without fans New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo wrote on Twitter
if our professional sports team can make
it work and be safe hunter and we are
supportive the announcements from the
states which are home to more than two
dozen franchises across the NFL and
a NHL and Major League Baseball don't
provide certainty as to how or when this
is going to happen but leagues are
making tentative plans to return MLB is
discussing a return to play proposal
with its players union has an eye on a
possible resumption of training next
month and a season beginning in early
July perhaps with teams playing in their
home cities and stadiums being grouped
geographically for scheduling purposes
to limit travel as well the NFL is not
scheduled to begin until September that
gives them some time to figure all of
this out so all of this is is very good
in Texas governor Greg Abbott has
already announced professional sports
can resume may 31st without any
spectators the pronouncements don't
resolve the league's return-to-play
issues but they bolster hopes that
sports can return a more widespread
basis in the coming weeks and months ok
so the fact is that Americans are ready
for this shutdown to be over they are
and they are acting as such I'm hopeful
that people are going to act responsibly
here I think it's very important that
people act responsibly here in fact we
already have some evidence that things
are not going to be as bad in terms of
in terms of the outbreak as people
originally suspected the Atlanta mayor
who is very very critical of the Georgia
governor she says listen this thing I
thought it was gonna be really terrible
I'm not so sure it's gonna be so
terrible anymore it's not as bad as I
thought that it would be so I am pleased
about that but I'd still think it's too
soon to say the reason being where it's
initially we were seeing increases
between deaths and people testing
positive rising anywhere from 25 to 30
percent over a seven day period right
now we're somewhere between 12 and 15
percent and so it's better than it was
but it's still not great okay well again
better than it was but so much it's
never gonna be great until this thing is
totally over but the fact that the
Atlanta mayor is now having to walk back
the Brian Kemp is going to kill
everybody routine is is pretty
astonishing because remember Brian Kemp
was evil he wanted to kill grandma so
that that is a that is a positive that
is a positive thing in in sort of
negative stuff there's police footage
showing a massive block party in Florida
yesterday people apparently were just
going out willy-nilly and then engaging
on a massive level and this does not
look like a socially distanced party
frankly if you take a look at this
footage you can see the helicopter is
is flashing this is Pensacola police
that released this footage people
associating in mass numbers listen
people still have to be careful if you
don't want to get Coppa 19 if you're
young and you don't care about getting
Coppa 19 I suppose that's on you
try not to infect somebody who is older
that would be the thing that we are most
focused on one of the big problems here
is that the lockdown was so severe and
so strict and now that people are are
being let out of jail basically they're
saying I'm gonna do what I want
willy-nilly now it is important to
recognize that by the way in Sweden that
actually is sort of what happened right
in Sweden there was this notion that
everybody was mask-wearing and socially
distancing no some people were but the
level of compliance was not actually
supremely high even in places like
Sweden the level of compliance is
actually kind of low in places like
Sweden is like 60% of the of the table
of the public was compliant now yeah you
don't actually need 100 percent of the
public complying in order to lower the
what they call the are not which is the
replication rate of the virus right all
you need is maybe 60 70 80 % of people
who are complying by the rules however
you do have a bit of a collective action
problem in that it is more fun to not
socially distance than to socially
distance and what this means is that the
people who are most calling for social
distancing and who are strictest when it
comes to these lock downs they better
have the courage of their convictions
well as it turns out they do not in fact
I'll give you an example so Bill
DeBlasio yesterday he said listen we're
just gonna pull you right out of the
water like if you go down to the beach
and then you get in the water you take
one foot you put it in the water and
Memorial Day will pull you out of the
water first of all let's just note
something Memorial Day the Atlantic
Ocean it's like 50 degrees something
people are willing nilly jumping into
the Atlantic Ocean on Memorial Day if
you've ever been in New York at this
time of year it don't work that way but
here was Bill DeBlasio anyway I'm trying
to suggest that he was going to
personally go and hustle people out of
the water fencing will be there but it
won't be implemented at first we're
hoping everyone just listens to the
rules follows the rules no swimming no
sports no gatherings no parties you know
just common sense observe social
distancing if you walk on the beach
remember don't go in the water not
supposed to go in the water it's a
dangerous situation to ever go in the
water when there's not lifeguards
present so there'll be a constant
reminder that anyone tries to get in the
water they'll be taken right out of the
water ok so so he sounds like he's going
to be very strict as far as how he
actually makes
this happened right well in reality he's
not gonna be that strict and I'll tell
you why he's not gonna be that strict
because it turns out that if he's
arresting people it is
disproportionately people of color and
this is upsetting folks so the New York
Times editorial board which was if you
go out without a massacre in and kill
people if you go out and use don't
social you since everybody is going to
die now the New York Times like you know
what maybe we shouldn't use the police
for this thing okay good luck done good
luck because the reality is that if you
actually want to enforce this thing then
you are going to have to you know
promulgate it by use of law enforcement
so this creates a bit of a catch-22 the
stricter you are in that which you call
for the less people are going to obey it
and the more you're gonna have to use
law enforcement which means that you
better be pretty obvious and open about
why people lead to social assistance you
better explain yourself
unfortunately authorities don't feel the
need to explain themselves instead they
just say things like we'll come and
we'll arrest you if you violate the
rules and well as you'll see these folks
do not have the courage of their
convictions they're not actually going
to arrest you if you don't buy it if you
violate the rules we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that one of the things that we
are finding out right now is that you
don't actually have to be on campus in
order to get a good education in fact
you're probably spending far far far far
too much money if you are spending money
on some ritzy campus that you can't
attend that was true before it is
certainly true now this is why Ashford
University is so useful when it comes to
your future it's time to drink dream big
the bigger the better the dream of a
better tomorrow starts with a degree
from Ashford University Ashford
University's online bachelor's and
master's degree programs allow you to
learn on a convenient and flexible
schedule at Ashford expert faculty will
teach you real-world skills from
real-world experience in online classes
built for life's twists and turns you
can learn from home or wherever you feel
comfortable you can pursue a degree in
one of Ashford 60-plus programs like
Business Administration Healthcare
Administration and psychology with 24/7
access to your classroom daily support
and financial aid available Ashford will
give you the tools you need to help make
your dreams a reality
you should stop putting things off go
get started today dare to dream big your
tomorrow starts today at Ashford
University there's no fee to apply or
standardized testing required to enroll
instead just go to Ashford edu slash pen
that is Ashford edu slash Ben Ashford
dot edu slash Ben not all programs
available in all states go check out
Ashford dot edu slash then cut out the
middleman don't spend money on campus
instead just go get the education needed
Ashford you
/ then hey so the in an attempt to drive
the idea that people need to socially
distance the media are going overboard
again being fully transparent with
people is probably the best way to do
all of this I feel like that's what I
try to do on the show and I try to give
you as much information as possible then
you make your own decisions cuz I trust
you as an individual human being to make
responsible decision so I've encouraged
you when you are in a populated area
particularly an area where you believe
they're going to be older and vulnerable
people should wear a mask I know there
are a lot of conservatives who are very
not on board with masks I don't fully
understand that I don't like wearing a
mask either it's annoying it's
irritating when I'm out on the streets
with my kids walking around away from
people I'm not wearing a mask because
that's stupid when I'm in my car alone
I'm not wearing a mask
if I go into a place that is populated
and enclosed I am wearing a mask mainly
because I don't want other people around
me to be infected with cope at 19 even
if I don't have cope at 19 I don't know
cuz it may be I have it and I'm
asymptomatic you just don't know so it
seems like a good caring thing to do but
the media are being deeply irresponsible
and how they are reporting this sort of
stuff so let me give you an example
there's an article from the UK Guardian
it says u.s. lockdown protests may have
spread virus widely cellphone data
suggests okay so you would imagine that
if the data were suggesting that the
protesters are this widely here's what
you would expect you would expect an
outbreak at a protest and then that that
outbreak was brought home by a bunch of
people and outbreaks where people
brought them where people brought you up
with the virus home right that's not the
article says all the article shows is
that people came from different places
to the protest and then went back to
different places and no point does it
shown an outbreak in any of those places
and no point does this article suggest
that there was an outbreak at the
protest instead all the article says his
cell phone location data suggests that
demonstrators had anti lockdown protests
some of which hadn't been connected with
Cova 19 cases are often traveling
hundreds of miles to events returning to
all parts of their states and even
crossing into neighboring lines the data
provided to the Guardian by the
progressive campaign group the Committee
to Protect Medicare shocker raises the
prospect the protests will play a role
in spreading coronavirus epidemics to
areas which have so far experienced
relatively few infections okay so at no
point do they actually demonstrate this
has happened instead they just say
people are traveling and that's
supposedly enough for us to determine
these protests are spreading the disease
far and wide now listen I may think that
it increased the risk of the spread of
the disease but that is not the same
thing as may have spread the disease for
online if you're gonna if you're gonna
say that that happened you actually have
to provide
some data to support it hey also there's
another great example of the media
panicking to try and suggest that things
are bad whether there's no evidence that
they're actually bad so Florida has been
a real black mark for the media media
really botched Florida because the media
treated it is the Rhonda census in
Florida was a bad bad very evil man and
wanted to kill Brahma and Florida was
gonna get absolutely shellacked by Cove
in nineteen and it turns out that
Florida with the population basically
the same as New York State has
experienced about one fifteenth one
twentieth of the deaths of New York
State it has not been hit anywhere near
the same as New York State so the new
report that the media are trying to push
out there is that a researcher a data
chief for Florida was fired and she
claimed without evidence without
presenting Eboni of any evidence that
she was fired because the Florida
government was trying to cover up bad
evidence with Cove in nineteen and this
is what everybody ran with and this was
the headline that everybody on Twitter
ran with on Twitter right now trending
architect and manager of Florida's Cove
in nineteen dash board says her vow her
removal was not voluntary and then
people start tweeting out that the
stance is covering up the data he's
covering up the data whoo he's covering
up the data except that's not what the
article says when you actually read the
article what it says is that this woman
claims that maybe she was fired for some
data reason she can't quite discern
here's what the article says she warned
she does not know what the new team's
intention are for data access including
what data they're now restricting so she
doesn't even claim that the data were
covered up in the aftermath of her
firing in her original note which she
posted on facebook said as a word of
caution I would not expect a new team to
continue the same level of accessibility
and transparency I made central to the
process during the first month after all
my commitment to both is largely
arguably entirely the reason I'm no
longer managing it okay well that's a
pretty big allegation Jones did not
respond to email requests to comment and
the Department of Health did not require
two inquiries from Florida today
regarding Jones removal and access to
data so if she's going to make that
accusation what you would imagine is
that the data would then go missing
right you wouldn't be able to access it
only one problem you can still access
all the data also she's provided no
evidence of her allegations also she
won't respond to media requests and then
the article basically quotes a bunch of
experts saying would be really bad if
Florida hid the data so the article does
not substantiate the allegation in any
way all it does say would it be bad to a
bunch of quantum court experts would it
be bad if they hid the data and yeah
that's what yes it would be very very
bad and this
ta'rhonda Santa's is firing people to
cover up the evidence ANCOVA 19 again
the evidence is not there that that's
happening also don't you think the media
would be all over it all over it if
Florida were experiencing a massive
uptick right now another example there's
a big story out of Georgia the story out
of Georgia is that in a public
presentation of a chart the Florida
government and the Georgia government
put together a bizarre chart in which
they sort of cited random dates in which
there was a downturn in cases to
demonstrate a clear charted downturn in
cases so instead of showing you a trend
line drawn through various states that
there were consistent instead they sort
of picked and chose dates that made the
trend line look clearer so instead of
showing every day what the trends line
were in terms of in terms of cases and
in diagnoses and deaths instead they
picked like the highest dates and then
the lowest dates and the media weren't
crazy all temp is trying to hide the
date he's trying to hide there's only
one problem with the he's trying to hide
the data argument the actual data
demonstrate that there's been about a
six percent reduction in the number of
infections in Georgia so he'd not have
to hide the data
it's just bad data management by
somebody on his comms team but that is
not him hiding a massive uptick in
Georgia because the massive uptick in
Georgia does not exist so again if you
want to push social distancing if you
want to push mask-wearing then how about
this how about we are accurate about
that which we are trying to push how
about you're transparent with the
American public because here's the
reality as I've said before I think it
was it was Jan McLaughlin on tour I
always want to credit people what I'm
forgetting the name there are only three
reasons why people obey the law one
because they think the law is good too
because they're being threatened three
because they're being bribed the problem
is you can't people you can't bribe
people to stay in their houses forever
because people don't actually like
staying in their houses this has been
pretty terrible and as for justifying to
people your policies our politicians
don't even feel the need to do that
which leaves you with coercion and now
as it turns out for all the talk about
from Lori Lightfoot in Chicago and the
governor of New Jersey Phil Murphy when
it comes to coercion the the authorities
don't actually want to utilize coercion
because the the disproportionate impact
of coercion is going to fall on poor and
minority communities apparently and this
is true New York City and then they will
be accused of racism so it turns out
that the coercion ain't gonna work
anyway Alex
in just one second it's hilarious the
New York Times which has been stumping
for lockdown lockdown lockdown lockdown
when they realize that that means the
NYPD is going to be issuing citations
largely to black and Hispanic people
then they're like well I guess we're not
so hot on the lockdown anymore are we
weird weird it'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact in the last few months have taught
us about what's important in life in
many ways but they've also taught us
what is important in business and that
means you have to be on top of your data
okay being efficient right now is not a
choice it is a necessity and if I don't
be efficient and how you run your
business you need to be transparent and
on top of all your data here's what you
need NetSuite by Oracle the world's
number one cloud business system a lot
of people use a variety of systems to
handle the sort of stuff it's not
integrated it's messy and you lose data
instead you need to be on top of your
finance HR inventory e-commerce
everything you need all in one place you
can save time money and headaches
whether you doing a million or hundreds
of millions in sales
NetSuite will give you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence NetSuite has
surveyed hundreds of business leaders
and assemble the playbook of the top
strategies they are using as America
reopens for business it would be a
mistake to blindly stumble through this
period as business you need to get
stronger you need to get fitter and you
need to get faster you know like the Six
Million Dollar Man receive your free
guide seven actions businesses need to
take right now and schedule your free
product tour at NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro again free guide schedule your
free product oil right now at NetSuite
comm slash appear that is n etsu ite
comm @ / up here in NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro go check them out right now hey
so as I say if there are three reasons
to obey a law one is that it makes sense
second it is you can be bribed and third
is coercion the first two have already
been taken off the table because bribery
ain't gonna work to keep people home
forever people don't want to be home
forever the one hanging out with each
other second doesn't wal make any sense
I'm not gonna follow Bill de Blasio's
prescriptions because he's blown all of
his credibility this is why it was so
important from the beginning
for our leaders to explain their
decision-making process and because they
refused to do so and because they were
not doing so in transparent or even
factual manner that led to a widespread
distrust of the authorities when it
comes to this stuff and so this means
radical transparency
right this means that we need to be very
clear about why it is that you are
wearing a mask the reason that you are
wearing a mask today folks is not to
protect yourselves the mask almost in a
filtering out particles at the rate
necessary to prevent you from getting
hope in nineteen masks are meant to
protect other people so if you're in a
place where you think there will be
people who are vulnerable and you should
wear a mask if you're in a place where
there are no people who are where there
are no people who are vulnerable then
there's a case that may be where the
mask isn't so important
seriously if you're around a bunch of
seventeen year olds like we're out the
other day on a Sunday and there are
bunch of teenage girls hanging out
together did I think to my said they
weren't wearing masks did I think to
myself oh my god danger for the Republic
not really I thought to myself okay well
there are young people if they get
covert 19 they're gonna be fine because
they're 17 right the the risk factors to
people who are seventeen is
extraordinarily low that's a choice is
it a choice that I think it's a great
choice not necessarily but it's a choice
they're gonna have to make and their
parents are going to have to help them
make as well I mean I assume their
parents know that they're hanging out
together or not wearing masks for the
most part
hey but with that said we are now down
to it we can't we have not justified our
policies and we have tried to bribe
people and that's not working so we are
now down to coercion and as it turns out
coercion tends to fall on people who are
not paying attention to the rules and so
I I need to point something out and this
is how this has been treated in New York
City so Bill DeBlasio tweeted yesterday
earlier today the NYPD shut down a new
Shiva conducting classes with as many as
70 children I can't stress how dangerous
this is for our young people we're
issuing a cease and desist order and
we'll make sure we keep our communities
and our kids safe it so first of all if
it's you Shiva for like people who are
ten there's very little evidence that
schools are dangerous for kids I mean
the Denmark never shut down in school
Sweden never shut down in schools much
of Europe never shut down at schools why
because kids are not really being
damaged by coronavirus in math numbers
or even in mild numbers as it turns out
like there there are statistical
outliers but there are real statistical
outliers but beyond that notice how the
Blasio every tweet he sends about a
group is always about the Jews and every
single one right these Jews gathering in
Williamsburg though those are bad Jews
we need to get the police out there and
break up the Jews oh man we had to break
up a we had to break up a wedding the
other day because of those Jews and now
as I've said if you are Jewish I have a
lot of Jewish listeners obviously
Orthodox Jew myself don't hold big
weddings without social distancing and
take great way to spread it to people
who are vulnerable just don't do it
right if you if you're going to engage
in in events socially distantly I've
been encouraging this for a while okay
so I've been consist
since on this but Bill DeBlasio only
talks about cheese ever but who's he
arresting is Bill DeBlasio arresting
Jews disproportionately Bill DeBlasio is
not arresting Jews disproportionally
Bill de Blasio's NYPD are arresting
people who are black and Hispanic now
this has led people on the left to
suggest this is because the NYPD is
racist is it possible maybe that Bill de
Blasio is picking on the Jews but the
reality is that people of various groups
are not socially distancing at the same
rate isn't it possible I know that would
cut against all of the all of the
narratives about how disparate
healthcare outcomes when it comes to
kovin 19 are entirely the result of
American racism but is it possible that
the disproportionate hit that the
Orthodox Jewish community took in terms
of Kobe 19 and the Orthodox Jewish
community did take a disproportionate
hit particularly in New York in terms of
komen 19 I know three separate people
all in the Orthodox community in New
York who died of cover 19 okay so the
Jewish community did take a
disproportionate hit was that because of
the racism and anti-semitism of the
healthcare system in New York or is it
because a lot of Jews got together right
around poram March 10th and they hung
out together and then they infected each
other and is it possible that the same
thing is true in men in minority
communities that are being hard-hit that
in order to actually chart whether
racism is to blame for America's health
care system disparities we actually have
to determine whether people are paying
attention to the social distancing or
not because as it turns out in New York
according to the New York Times of the
125 people arrested over offenses that
law enforcement officials described as
related to the chronal virus pandemic
113 were black or Hispanic are you
getting that of the 125 people arrested
113 were black or Hispanic in New York
City so does that mean the bill de
blasio is a racist that's 90 percent of
people who have been arrested in New
York City for not obeying the law ANCOVA
19 are black or Hispanic of the 374
summonses from March 16th to May 5th
300 were given to black and Hispanic New
Yorkers that's 80 percent videos of some
of the arrests are hard to watch in one
posted to Facebook last week a group of
some six police officers are seen
tackling the black woman in a subway
station as her young child looks on
she's got a baby with her a bystander
shouts
police officials told the Daily News the
woman had refused to comply when
officers directed her to put the mask
she was wearing over her nose and mouth
contrast that with photographs across
social media showing crowds of
sunseekers packed into parks in wealthy
whiter area
of the city lounging undisturbed as
police officers hand out masks so it is
obvious the city needs a different
approach to enforcing public health
measures during the pandemic Mayor Bill
DeBlasio seems to understand this he's
promised to hire two hundred two
thousand three hundred people to serve
as social distancing ambassadors how
good luck with this so there are new
idea is they're gonna go around warning
people they're gonna build the public
health core to enforce social distancing
measures they don't have the power to
punish or fine or anything they have the
power to walk up to you and scold you
yes I'm sure scolding is going to go
incredibly well in New York City homes
who the vast majority of the United
States a-holes
have you met New Yorkers like that is
not a criticism of New Yorkers they're
wonderful a-holes but let's be real
about New Yorkers okay like I spent an
awful lot of time in New York New
Yorkers are not known for being tactful
and polite that is not their thing
New Yorkers are brash it is their a
homeless that makes them uniquely
American you think that walking around
saying to New Yorkers you know you
really should socially distensae me hey
f you get out of here
I'd like to this in this approach
especially training civilians could fan
out across neighborhoods in parks
helping with pedestrian traffic control
and politely encouraging New Yorkers
entering parks to protect one another by
wearing masks and keeping their distance
and Police Department School Safety
agents who are not armed could help such
a program could also provide much-needed
employment for young people ah so that's
the real purposes we're going to hire a
bunch of scolds to go around telling
people to socially distance the police
department according to the New York
Times would play only a minimal role in
this approach stepping in to up with
crowd control for example something it
does extremely well without a
significant course correction the
department's role in the Pens I think
may look more like stop and frisk the
policing tactic that led to the
harassment of hundreds of thousands of
innocent people most of them black and
Hispanic while rarely touching white New
Yorkers so again it's hilarious the New
York Times was fine when de Blasio was
screaming at the Jews but the minute
that it turns out that the people who
are being arrested are largely black and
Hispanic just like by the way most of
the criminal arrests in New York City
then all of a sudden it turns into the
NYPD is racist in the only way that we
can really do this is to recommend the
course of action just the New York Times
is double standard with regard to which
groups are worthy of criticism is really
something to be holding the same thing
is true of Bill de Blasio but it does
underscore he basic truth here that
libertarians have been speaking for a
very long
time if you are not willing to enforce a
law do not put the law on the books and
if you're going to inform people as to
why they ought to pursue certain action
on a voluntary basis you need to be more
transparent about how you are making
those decisions otherwise people have no
incentive to do this and again I cannot
think of something more ready for
late-night TV then a bunch of schoolmarm
hall monitors walking around the streets
of Crown Heights telling people they
need to socially distance a good
freaking luck good luck okay in just a
second so this is this is all the news
that actually matters because this is
how we're gonna reopen it's about
whether we're gonna be responsible when
we reopen it's about the consequences
politically for people on the Left who
actually want lock downs right it's all
about the health data now we're gonna
get to the stuff that the media decided
that was very important to cover over
the last 24 hours
suffice it to say it is not important
things we'll get to that momentarily
first let us talk about the fact that
right now you don't want to be going to
the auto parts store right do you really
want to be waiting in line at the auto
parts store you're gonna wait in line is
that really the place you want to be to
spend too much money for the wrong part
or that and just get to the front of the
line and the person's like well I can
put that on order for you yeah I know or
you could just order it yourself at Rock
Auto calm rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do well I spend up to twice as
much for the same part rockauto.com is a
family business they serve Auto Parts
customers online they've been doing so
for 20 years go to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers I
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need Rock auto comm head
on over to rockauto.com right now no
reason to spend too much money go to
Wroclaw don't come right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you again that is Rock Auto comm go
check them out right now don't spend too
much money on your auto parts Rock Auto
calm and write shapiro in their hell did
you hear about us box ok first in
exciting news my new book is now
available for presale guys like really
go out and buy my new book as you are
well aware americans are now more
divided than ever and they're looking to
get more divide it just yesterday then
your
reported that Joe Biden wants to
completely undermine many of America's
institutions we've seen Barack Obama out
there suggesting we need fundamental
transformative change in the United
States nothing could be more divisive
than this in a time of coronavirus
pandemic we're seeing serious divisions
over issues that should be unifying take
for example the fact that the 16:19
project by the New York Times about the
dark roots of slavery as part of our
country's history was actually about how
America is rooted in slavery and based
on slavery and this has become the road
talking point for large swaths of the
Democratic Party this was rewarded with
a Pulitzer earlier this month
I devote a huge section in my book how
to destroy America in three easy steps
that's the name of the book how to
destroy America in three easy steps to
examining its intent as well as its
content if you don't have a copy yet you
can pre-order one at daily wire.com /ban
or you can find it at Amazon or Barnes
and Noble it's available for pre-order
right now right now in America they're
fundamentally two different visions for
the country on the table one is unifying
its finds our unity what keeps us
together in a shared philosophy culture
in history the other disintegrates our
country and sees us all as various
interest groups that are basically
bashing each other about the skull for
control of the government that is an
image that the left wants to push and in
that push is destroying the country from
within in this election this 2020
election is very much about that so
oddly enough has the pandemic response
it has become a referendum and how you
view the country and whether the country
requires fundamental change every time
you see Democrats out there suggesting
that kovat has really exposed the deep
roots of American injustice and we need
to remake the system that is what we're
talking about that is a step toward the
destruction of the country my new book
is called how to destroy America in
three easy steps it talks about what
should bring Americans together and how
those who want this integration are
tearing the country apart again head on
over to Daley wire.com slash bend and
order your copy today you're listening
some largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk about now what
the media want you to talk about today
they don't want you to talk about the
vaccines they don't want you to talk
about the stock market they don't want
you to talk about the reopening of the
states and whether the data are
supporting a downturn they don't want
you to talk about any of that stuff they
don't talk about Trump going after the
whu-oh they want to talk about one thing
and one thing only yesterday President
Trump announced he was taking
hydroxychloroquine oh okay so here's my
view on this I'm not a doctor
oh are you doctor do you know here's
what we know about hydroxychloroquine in
several studies hydroxychloroquine alone
has not been shown to have any power to
cure this coven 19 there was a study
that came out from NYU and it showed
that hydroxychloroquine in combination
with the throw myosin a z-pack and zinc
improved coronavirus patients chances of
being discharged and cut the deaths
death risk by almost 50% researchers at
NYU Grossman School of Medicine looked
in 932 coronavirus patients hospitalized
between March 2nd and April 5th half
were given a combination of
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin and zinc
sulfate the other half didn't get zinc
patients receiving the triple drug
combination or 1.5 times more likely to
recover enough to be discharged and 44%
less likely to die if you took just
hydroxychloroquine and as if for myosin
and no zinc then basically there was no
impact on your health outcome so
President Trump didn't just say who's
taking hydroxychloroquine he also said
he was taking zinc and z packs now
should you be taking that preemptively
before you have koban 19 I haven't seen
any studies on people who are taking
this stuff preemptively I haven't right
and I'm not sure any studies have
actually been done about that but
Trump's doctor who presumably doesn't
want the President of the United States
to drop dead of a heart attack on his
watch said that President Trump can take
it so I assume Trump isn't going in the
back and drink in the fish tank cleaner
right I assume that the President of the
United States is actually following his
doctor's advice now is it possible the
doctor wouldn't advise this in the first
place sure is it also possible the Trump
wants him and said listen I keep hearing
this stuff about hydroxychloroquine and
I hear about zinc and it's it reminds
him the people are telling me I've heard
many paper many expert paper and doctors
like listen there's some studies it
shows that it's kind of effective I
don't think you have a high health risk
because you have a pretty good heart we
do like a
Kolani every year you don't have a
history of heart difficulty so sure I
mean it can't really hurt and then Trump
took it that seems to me the most likely
thing again do you really think that
Trump's doctors the doctors for the
President of the United States like mr.
president if you want to take that fish
tank cleaner you just go right ahead and
down it and if you die it would be my
fault
like who thinks the doctors are thinking
that way it's not like Trump is just
disobeying his doctors and then buying
opioids off the streets and shooting
them into his veins like what the hell
are you talking okay so here was
President Trump yesterday saying he was
taking hydroxychloroquine and then the
world ends because dr. Pelosi arrives to
talk about and dr. Cuomo arrives to talk
about it again there many doctors who
say you should not take
hydroxychloroquine to fight this thing
and you shouldn't take it alone there's
literally no evidence that if you take
hydroxychloroquine alone that is going
to help you in any way or even if you
take hydroxychloroquine with is a
thorough myosin that'll help you in any
way there's some evidence from that and
why you study again I'm studying the
study okay from NYU School of Medicine
and if you take the three-pack right the
z-pak and the ether Allah and E and the
zinc and hydroxychloroquine the reason
this matters is hydroxychloroquine
apparently sort of opens the the ability
of cells to absorb zinc which is good
for fighting Koba 19 if you do that
after you have a cup of 19 there's some
evidence that this is effective in
treatment okay that's that's all we know
I've given you all the things we know
but he rose from Pastor day announcing
that he's taking hydroxychloroquine
everybody going nuts and you'd be
surprised at how many people are taken
and especially the frontline workers
before you catch it the frontline
workers many many are taking it I happen
to be taking it I happen to be taking it
couple of weeks ago started taking it
because I think it's good I've heard a
lot of good stories and if it's not good
I'll tell you right doctor to get hurt
by it okay so everybody's like you're
not a doctor mr. president right but
you're also not his doctor and again do
you really imagine the President of the
United States is just downing the fish
tank cleaner in the back room without
the doctor overseeing it it's a Neil
Cavuto on Fox he says okay you should
not take as a throw you should not take
hydroxi because you will die so don't
don't go ahead and do that again there's
a difference between the president
saying I'm taking it and everybody else
should take it okay that you should go
to your doctor and ask about things
before you take drugs as husband
of a doctor you know it's a thing I do
before I take anything I asked my wife
because she is a doctor you should
always ask your doctor before you start
taking drugs of any sort
I assume that President Trump has done
that because again the White House
doctor does not want to be on the table
when the president dies of a heart
attack that is not a good look
here was Neil Cavuto though informing
the American people don't take it or
you're gonna die the VA study to which
the president alluded wasn't a loaded
political one it was a test on patience
there and those who took it in a
vulnerable population including those
with respiratory other conditions they
died I want to stress again they died if
you are in a risky population here and
you are taking this as a preventive
treatment to ward off the virus or in a
worst case scenario you are dealing with
the virus and you are in this vulnerable
population it will kill you I cannot
stress enough this will kill you okay
this will kill you if you take it back
that again it may not kill you it does
raise the risk of heart attack okay like
that's what the studies show it does
raise a risk it's not just an effective
if you take it without the zinc and
without these internal medicine without
Kobe 19 it could absolutely raise your
risk of dying of heart attack right
that's what the studies show so Kabuto
is is not wrong that you could die from
it he doesn't say you won't inevitably
kill you okay it's not like you take the
hydroxy and then you absolutely die but
there's no benefit and there is
increased risk that is the more proper
way of putting this then you have Chris
Cuomo going off now
Chris Cuomo has zero credibility on this
when we talk about people who have no
credibility talk about health solutions
to Kovan 19 his wife literally was
bathing in bleach I'm not kidding you
his wife put out a statement she had
cocoa 19 he had Kobe 19 she put out like
a giant statement talked about on the
show about all the weird crap she's
doing that she apparently got from like
wouldn't Paltrow's goop or something
where she's like well you know I took
some bleach and I poured it in I took
some Clorox I put it in the bathtub and
then I bathed in the Clorox okay Chris
sit down dude like really sit down
didn't even pay attention to his own
quarantine who's going out going to a
second house here's Chris Cuomo going
off on how could the president beat this
non health conscious again you're
basically like waving dreamcatchers in
the air and doing rain dances to stop
Cobin 19 dude you don't get to talk on
this he wins this argument why because
he believes because he's taking a chance
because he's strong he's not the party
of no he's not the Democrats no don't
take the hydroxychloroquine just in case
you stay home you can't go out you can't
work you can't eat you can't live that's
where he's put the democrats some of its
messaging but some of its more than that
he's such an idiot my god isn't this man
what a dolt seriously what a dolt it's
pretty amazing that Mario Cuomo's name
alone could make his son governor and
Chris Cuomo gets a job on CNN what what
idiocy okay the best comment of course
was reserved for Nancy Pelosi who gets
on TV and then tells Anderson Cooper
this is real news right here that
President Trump shouldn't be taking
hydroxychloroquine says dr. Pelosi
because he's morbidly obese now let me
just ask a question in the aftermath of
this when is it now okay to fat train
people because I was informed this is
very bad here's Nancy Pelosi saying the
president he's just so fat he's super
fat fat fatty fat McFadden him he's fat
so bad very bad bad as far as the
president is concerned the our police
our president and I would rather he not
be taking something that has not been
approved by the scientists especially in
his age group and in his shall we say
weight group had but it is morbidly
obese they say so I think that was it's
not a good idea it's just so she calls
him morbidly obese and then it was like
Slade Queen on Twitter right this is the
stuff people care about not the not the
vaccine not the stock market not how
we're reopening not the impact of any of
that not the President of the United
States going after the whu-oh not the
fact that we now have more tests
available in most states than people to
take the tests not the fact that we now
have a surplus event none of that is
newsworthy the newsworthy thing is that
Pelosi called Trump a fatty Matt fat fat
McPhatter fataroo
he's China sleep at president plump was
trending on Twitter cuz Trump pimp dem
Trump is it a few questions one does
this mean that we now get to point out
when politicians are more morbidly obese
him
point that out now like is that okay
because I've been informed reliably by
the media that it's very importantly
points out of politicians are morbidly
obese because that does make a
difference in terms of their overall
health quota so do we get to like look
at the way to Stacey Abrams now or no do
we get to like again I don't know chris
Christie like I relied to say this sort
of stuff for it only applies to
Republicans you can say the Chris
Christie's of fátima calf at but if he
points out that JB Pritzker the governor
of Illinois that dude needs to be
lowered into the Illinois State House by
crane that that apparently that
apparently is very very bad you're not
allowed to do that at all like when does
this apply I think that the rule on
Twitter is that it's okay to call Trump
a fatty make fat fat McPhatter
big orange fat man you're allowed to say
that but you are not allowed to say that
anybody else is fat ever especially
celebrities right if a celebrity female
particularly is plump right if a
celebrity female is morbidly obese like
in bad health morbidly obese
you cannot point that out because that's
body shaming so so much so that if
somebody who is slightly overweight or
somewhat oval right but not morbidly
obese like a doe loses a bunch of weight
then we have to yell at her about losing
the weight we have to talk about how
it's very bad she's undermined
she's bought into society's standards of
beauty well maybe Trump just didn't buy
to your standards of beauty people maybe
Trump believes that actual round oranges
are beautiful how do you know okay I
gotta say the person who's gonna enjoy
this most of all is Trump because now
Trump just gets to talk about Nancy
Pelosi's immovable face for the last 25
years like from that he never had any
problem going there in the first place
but now the media have no leg to stand
on after shouting slay queen at the moon
because Nancy Pelosi was like he's Mar
picking up he's now the President of the
United States is gonna be like yeah well
her face hasn't moved in 25 years I mean
look at her she's like a Roman statue
she like there's so much Botox in there
her face froze in place yeah when I was
a kid my parents told me that if I made
an ugly face it would stay that way
forever Nancy Pelosi it's the reality
like you know Trump's gonna go here now
right and very important stuff very
important stuff so we have to focus on
the fact that Trump is taking
hydroxychloroquine and is overweight
very very important stuff our media man
focusing on the things that matter by
the way speaking of the media focusing
on things that matter you want to talk
about some more media malpractice this
is a pretty great story so this started
trending today also The Daily Beast
reported that Trump will not unveil
Obama's White House portrait so normally
the current president will bring the
ex-president and then unveil the White
House portrait at the White House Trump
isn't going to do that but here is the
actual story Obama doesn't wanted to do
it right the real story is that Obama
preemptively shut this thing down
according to NBC Obama has quote no
interest in taking part in the tradition
as long as Trump occupies the White
House so it was actually Obama who shut
it down preemptively and the media blame
Trump he's tactless and he's crass how
terrible how terrible so that is a that
is another aspect of media malpractice
but I'll tell you what the media know
that we shouldn't cover we certainly
should not cover Obama gate in any way
no covering of the Obama gate also the
media have figured out that believe all
women is a right-wing trap so that's
exciting stuff
there's an entire op ed in the New York
Times yesterday suggesting that the
slogan believe all women was made up by
the right-wing in order to trap the
Democrats this is great from now on the
Democrats just can't get to claim that
every stupid thing they ever say is made
up by Republicans which is super
extraordinarily fun apparently from each
according to his ability to each
according to his knee it needs is a
right-wing slogan because it's failed
every time it's tried so it must be that
the right has somehow boxed everybody
him already
time for some things that I hate the
media are desperate desperate to defend
President Obama to every extent possible
and this is why if you say a bad word
about President Obama then you will be
covered as though you have committed a
grave brutal sin my friend Meghan McCain
yesterday the view said something
perfectly obvious about Barack Obama I
mean like 100% perfectly obvious and
that is that Barack Obama is not
innocent in the cultural wars the Barack
Obama in fact was a progenitor of the
culture wars and an eager participants
in the culture wars and continues to be
an eager participants in the culture
wars right that has been obviously true
it was Barack Obama who suggested that
Trayvon Martin could have been his son
in the middle of a contentious legal
dispute over a disputed shooting in
Florida it was Barack Obama who
suggested the Cambridge police acted
stupidly
who's Barack Obama who suggested that
the Michael Brown verdict in st. Louis
in Ferguson Missouri was unjustified it
was Barack Obama
who suggested that big businesses ought
to obey him because the pitchforks were
outside it was Barack Obama who's
ripping into Fox News and every
available opportunity was Barack Obama
who was shining a rainbow flag on the
White House after the Supreme Court
baselessly decided the Constitution of
the United States mandates gay marriage
Barack Obama's an eager participants in
the cultural words Jews never saw a TV
show he didn't want to be a part of he
never saw a sports event he couldn't
parachute into and try and grab the
attention ok so Meghan McCain points
this out then she basically says and
then Trump has exacerbated those
cultural conflicts but Obama started
them and the media went nuts over this
because Obama must be protected at all
costs obviously everyone on the Left has
basically appointed President Obama as
nothing short of a saint and obviously I
feel different as most Republicans and
conservatives do I will say I the
culture war that I believe is real and
is raging in this country I believe was
ushered in with his administration and
then exacerbated in the Trump
administration and if the election were
held today I do believe Trump would be
reelected and I think at a certain point
we have to start talking to each other
in the middle okay this is exactly right
choose trended finished how dare she say
Obama in Trump in the same sense we must
never utter Obama's name it Poli it's
like the it's like the anti Baltimore
you must never say Obama you must simply
say the one
if you ever say Obama in a bad context
is because they are very very evil and
also racist and Megan McCain is clearly
evil and also racist for saying it
perfectly obvious thing so the media's
latest iteration of this stupidity is
the unwillingness to cover so-called
Obama gate so again Obama gate is about
the idea the basic theory of Obama gate
is very simple and that is that the
Obama administration had to convinced
itself the Trump and Russia were in
collusion and that is the reason the
president Trump won the election and
then they basically loosed at the hounds
and allowed them to bend all the rules
in the attempt to demonstrate what they
thought was a foregone conclusion which
is that Trump and Russia were colluding
in order to shift the election and then
that in the aftermath of from selection
they were going to undermine America's
security by working with the Russians
right that is Obama gate now does that
mean criminal activity took place not at
the top levels it could have been that
people at the top levels were like you
know I'm kind of interested to see what
this one thing is about we should find
out whether Flynn talked to the Russians
and then I'm asked him that's not
illegal
it is illegal to leak it so not
everything that is bad is illegal as we
have found out over and over and over
right Trump has done a bunch of stuff
that I think is bad but also that is not
illegal like I don't think Trump should
have gotten on the horn with Ukraine
with the Ukrainian politicians and been
like you know what it would be really
great if you could go investigate
Purisima and Joba like I don't think
that that was a smart thing to do I
think it was a bad thing to do I said
this many many times do I think that it
was illegal the way he did it no I don't
I don't think Eve I elated a bribery law
I don't think he violated an extortion
law I don't think that he violated any
law I don't think I should have done it
anyway Barack Obama did many things
during his tenure that were bad but not
illegal
Obama Gate falls under the category of
bad but not illegal except for the
people who actually violated the law by
leaking to the press illegally or by
using FISA warrants illegally but the
media have decided it's totally not
worth covering so imagine an opposite
situation in which Donald Trump was
firmly convinced that Barack Obama was
in the pocket of the Pakistani
government and so he decided you know
what there was a conversation between
Susan Rice and the Pakistani government
I want to unmask Susan Rice in that
conversation and then you know somebody
leaks it they can only get whatever
imagine that he was like you know what
it's very important we get Susan Rice's
phone on tap the former national
security adviser we get her phone on tap
and we need to tap her phone and if you
need to bend some of the rules to do it
you just kind of go ahead and you do
that and his people come to and say
listen there's no basis for the
investigation like well would be good if
it stayed open anyway would that be a
scandal obviously it would be a scandal
but according to the media if you cover
Obama gate it's only because you're a
Trump Lackey it's only because you're a
Trump Lackey
now again you don't have to buy into the
darkest version of Obama gate which is
that Obama knew everything was directing
it like a puppeteer top down was telling
people explicitly to violate the law and
all of this you don't have to believe
any of that to believe that bad stuff
went on and that it is not good when an
outgoing administration is basically
loosing the hounds of war on the
incoming administration on the basis of
skimpy or no evidence that that is a bad
thing in fact you know who believes that
theory of the case right they the non
crazed and the non over-the-top theory
of the case is William bar the creditor
in general right so William bar was
asked specifically about the Russian
inquiry whether it was an Obama ply said
no he said are you gonna prosecute Obama
invited no right this is Bill Barr these
supposed it Lackey of the Trump
administration who only violates law on
behalf of
Trump administration the Durham
investigation is trying to get to the
bottom of what happened and it will
determine whether there were any federal
laws broken and if there were those who
broke the laws will be held to account
but this cannot be and it will not be a
tit for tat exercise as to President
Obama and Vice President Biden whatever
their level of involvement based on the
information I have today I don't expect
mr. Durham's work will lead to a
criminal investigation of either man
okay so that is a perfectly reasonable
thing for bar to say people are being
reasonable and how they are pursuing
this at the level of the Trump
administration but that does not mean
that is not worth looking into when you
are talking about several violations of
law at minimum Malley Hemingway has a
good piece on this over at the
Federalist talking about the the media
failing to report on all of this and she
says many of our supposedly marked me
smart media elites are dinosaurs who are
completely unaware of the asteroid
headed right to them instead they are
doing it their part in an
all-hands-on-deck effort to continue
pushing out Democratic talking points
that got them into this mess this week
that meant they regurgitated the
Democratic claim that the Obama
administration's spying and leaking was
normal and that to be concerned about it
is nothing more than a distraction
Susan Glasser at The New Yorker
suggested that acknowledging the Obama
administration's recorded attempts to
undermine a duly elected administration
through spying and leaking was a form of
political agitprop her husband Peter
Baker at the New York Times took the
same line but when with the
authoritative gas sledding approach in
which he suggested it was odd that Trump
would want to correct the false
narrative and who's a traitor to his
country and replace it with the truth
that he was a victim of a coordinated
attack to spying his campaign criminally
leaked against him and forced him out of
office Jake Tapper reported for duty to
spread this partisan talking point as
well she says the big problem with
covering the story honestly is that it
might help Trump and Republicans but
they should look to left-wing journalist
who are able to put aside their genuine
dislike of the orange Batman and his Co
partisans and retain their journalistic
integrity among the few journalists on
the right who covered these issues well
there are many who weren't particularly
fond of Trump she says look the reality
is that we know that people inside the
Obama administration
who are firmly convinced that they were
going to get Trump here and that they
then basically bent the rules in order
to go after Trump and that again is the
story but if you even cover it then you
are doing the work of Trump and this is
where the media's obvious bias comes out
so now the media are going back to 2016
and we shouldn't have covered Hillary's
emails it was a nonentity was a
non-story we never should have covered
Hillary's emails again it seems worth
covering when the former Secretary of
State set up her own private server so
that all of her mail including
government mail was going through her
server and there would be no record of
it and she could wipe it clean that is a
very very large story in fact it is in
fact a violation of law hey James Comey
lied when he rewrote the law in order to
avoid the implication that Hillary
Clinton had violated the law if you
don't want a prosecutor what he should
have said is listen she did violate the
law we don't prosecute everybody who
violates the law because the reality is
the common practice sometimes means that
we sort of looked the other way but he
wasn't gonna be that honest
in fact Jim's coming came out he
basically made the case for why Hillary
should be prosecuted and then he was
like what we're not gonna prosecute her
but the media are very angry at
themselves because by covering the
emails they made that top line issue
there was an entire study that came out
yesterday showing sort of how many
people associated various words with the
various campaigns and the number one
word associated with Hillary Clinton in
2016 was emails so the media regret this
so this leads Margaret Sullavan formerly
the publisher of the New York Times to
say we should not have covered any of
this she's over at the Washington Post
she says it's becoming clear that
journalists never reckoned with the
mistakes of the 2016 campaign coverage
we know this because they seem poised to
repeat them as you may recall the news
media from Fox News to the New York
Times and plenty of others across the
political spectrum managed to make the
relative molehill of Hillary Clinton's
dicey email practices into a daily
obsession roughly equal to the mountain
of Donald Trump's financial and personal
transgressions hey let me just note
Donald Trump was not a member of
government Donald Trump see now if I
like the law Donald from violates Donald
Trump did not hand over his IRS records
that's not a crime
Donald Trump has been audited by the IRS
several times if he's gonna be pretty
criminally prosecuted you would imagine
somebody would have done it already
Hillary Clinton was a member of
government who violated the law as a
member of government one of those things
was very very noteworthy but Margaret
Sullavan says don't look now this is
happening again before our eyes it's
named this time is Obama gate that's
among moniker
that in president Trump's outrage tweets
is rendered in all capital letters
letters but let's not this vaporous
apparently made-up offence according to
trump is the political crime of the
century and heck last century too
because he claims it makes the 1970s
Watergate scandal look like child's play
as best as he too even attempted to
spell out it supposedly involves a deep
state conspiracy by the former president
and his allies to undermine Trump by
being informed of the identity of
private citizens having covert and
legally questionable discussions with
the Russian ambassador a citizen who
turned out to be Trump's national
security adviser designate Michael Flynn
despite the fact that this practice is
legal and normal the non scandal around
it is getting plenty of attention okay
so a couple things can be true one
unmasking is legal and it is normal
unmasking by half the administration of
an incoming national security adviser
and then the leaking of that advisors
name to the media is not normal and the
leaking is not illegal and chris wallace
is sunday morning interview show a
bottom of the chyron bottom of the
screen Perrin red is Obama gate an
effective campaign strategy Trump water
carrier Karl Rove was allowed to alpine
there are some very serious questions
that need to be answered it does stink
Juan Williams tried to pour water on
this nonsense there's no Obama gait he
said bluntly declaring Trump's blather a
smokescreen to distract from his
disastrous handling of coronavirus still
the conversation about the non scandal
went on for almost seven minutes on this
popular show at the nation's
most-watched cable network at CBS 2 News
Catherine Herridge has been heavily
hyping her updates on the non story
scoop she declared on Twitter to Herald
her story that acting at DNI Richard
Grinnell had notified Congress about the
great unmasking CBS is hiring of Harwich
the Harwich says says Margaret Sullavan
from Fox News last year was sharply
criticized by liberals who were called
to persistent reporting on the Clinton
email debacle and onto both allegations
that the former Secretary of State
personally approved the diminishment of
security at the Benghazi compound in
Libya before the 2012 attack there so
let's just say Obama gates getting
plenty of attention across the media
spectrum this ledge shaw nailing a box
you by the way I like Sean I mean he's a
nice guy you know I correspond he said
watching the media pounced on his story
like greyhounds chasing mechanical
rabbits has been painful but also deeply
familiar and it's so horribly familiar
because we have failed to learn very
much if anything about how much
attention to give exaggerated pseudo
scandals hilarious the media that spent
three years saying that undoubtedly
Trump would be uncovered as a Russian
catspaw is now saying it's a pseudo
scandal to investigate whether or not
members of the Obama administration were
bending and
the rules in order to follow their
hearts and the suggestion that Donald
Trump was in fact a Russian Kasbah
amazing amazing stuff and then the media
like trust us okay here's the deal we
don't and when you suggest openly that
you are not going to cover a story
because you do not like the political
implications of that story when you
suggest that retrospectively Hillary
Clinton's emails were a big nothing
burger when they in fact were not a
nothing burger all that shows is that
you're upset that you were honest about
Hillary Clinton and so now you plan on
being dishonest in the future that's the
basic idea here which of course goes to
undermining media credibility evermore
okay we'll be back here a little bit
later to do two additional hours of
content also tonight I am hosting all
access live you should go subscribe
right now at daily wire comm slash
subscribe and become a member and you
can hang out with me tonight as I
perform various stupid human tricks and
wear a t-shirt that's basically the
pitch say that you're into it or you're
not but you can go subscribe right now
and join the club and hangout with us in
this time of pandemic otherwise we'll
see you here later today or tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the bench Bureau
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2025 as Pro
lockdown leftists get shriller in their
calls to lock everyone at home from
coast to coast everyone from cops to
judges to ordinary people are wising up
to the simplest way to stop them call
their bluff just weeks after promising
his own lockdown order on saving just
one life New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
is promising that lots of grannies are
going to die what a difference to months
and a lot of failed policies makes and
the gaslighting me to movement is now
pretending they never told us to believe
all women do they think that we don't
have Google all that and more check it
out on the Michael Nolan
[Music]
you